hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24
en español el mundo vive momentos de
máxima tensión desde que el conflicto
ruso-ucraniano tomó la peor de las
dimensiones posibles con la decisión del
presidente ruso vladimir putin de
invadir ucrania y en esta emisión de la
entrevista vamos a abordar la guerra
desde una perspectiva social y cultural
y es por eso que nos acompaña alejandro
rabinovich él es doctor en historia y
civilización por la escuela de altos
estudios en ciencias sociales de parís
también es investigador del conicet
hablamos del consejo nacional de
investigaciones científicas y técnicas
de argentina alejandro rabinovich
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
esta entrevista
muchas gracias un gusto no gracias a
usted una vez más alejandro bueno desde
el punto de vista tradicional analizar
la guerra implicaba seguir esta idea de
que se trata de una suerte de
continuación no de la política pero por
otros medios no sea como una suerte de
instrumento más que tiene para echar la
mano cualquier gobierno pero usted ha
separado el estudio de la guerra de esa
perspectiva y analiza su historia social
no desde esta visión se puede hablar
entonces de una sociedad guerrera verdad
como es esa sociedad de 'alejandro'
fue la pregunta porque justamente la
estrés social y cultural de la guerra
parte de esta idea de que cónclave
suites con esta idea de que la guerra es
sólo la continuación de la política por
otros medios no nos alcanza para
entender las causas de la guerra de los
motivos las consecuencias porque hay
sociedades que se ven profundamente
afectadas por este fenómeno y que
pierden a adaptarse a ese fenómeno y
luego entonces lo reproducen entonces
vemos no haciendo un poquito puntual
como estoy en tiempo real sino más en un
largo plazo con otro tipo de tiempos
como la guerra se transforma en una
parte esencial de marcos culturales que
forman una sociedad que por ende no
siempre son solamente una cuestión
pasional o de costo-beneficio o
puramente utilitaria los gobiernos que
utilizan la guerra como si fueron un
ajedrez como un problema lo que tiene
que ver con lo que hace posible que esos
vestidores de política puedan usar la
guerra no que trata de sants en una
sociedad
el presidente puede decidir a la guerra
el pueblo no siga
un general o un presidente pueden decir
lo que sea en cualquier contexto y
salirse con la solución multiplicador
condiciones sociales que permitan que
eso sea una opción viable en caso de la
guerra una tragedia que nos ocupa y nos
preocupa hace muchísimo tiempo y
entonces es interesante intentar ver
cuáles son las causas
ahora voy a leer una cita tuya alejandro
ha dicho la guerra es en buena medida un
fenómeno cultural esto está muy
vinculado a lo que venía diciendo
podrías desarrollar esta idea un poco
más para nuestra audiencia
clic hay parámetros que hacen no ahora
desde siempre que hacen que ciertas
culturas tengan como uno de los
elementos centrales a la guerra ya la
violencia armada recordemos que hace
nomás 100 años la parte esencial de lo
que se llevaba a hacerse hombre era un
primer combate y la mayoría de las
personas tenía una experiencia militar
bélica ya sea como soldados como
milicianos en algún momento de su vida
preferentemente en la juventud y formado
parte de la experiencia cotidiana de la
mayor parte de la población nosotros
tenemos la suerte nosotros vivimos los
que estamos vivos ahora y a su mente 30
años de que la segunda guerra mundial
tenemos el privilegio de que en buena
parte de occidente la guerra ha salido
de nuestras vidas
o se volvió muy rara y entonces nos está
costando vas a entender este tipo de
conflictos porque nos resulta llamativo
no resulta extraño la gran mayoría de
las personas que viviendo un país
occidental no ven la vocación militar
como la salida principal un cierre en
otro momento ni tienen una afinidad con
este tipo de cosas ni les va a tocar
invadan su país sin tener que salir a
combatir como están haciendo los
ucranianos por eso cuando vemos estas
imágenes nos choque ella es muy
importante entender que la guerra no
desapareció en estos últimos años y
desde la segunda guerra mundial y los
publicados en desastres en la shoá y en
nagasaki e hiroshima
un cambio tremendo en la tendencia
bélica en la cual el pico de guerra que
se estuvo haciendo cambio cada vez más
hace un tipo de conflicto en el cual ya
no eran las potencias ni los estados con
sus ejércitos de línea los que chocaban
el uno contra el otro sino que
viajecitos guerras asimétricas
entre un estado y cada vez más grupos
irregulares o insurgentes que se
enfrentaba en ese estado y es en los
últimos 20 años se transformó de
tendencia en la realidad absoluta la
guerra sigue existiendo pero hasta hoy
hasta esta semana no había guerras de
este tipo no había guerras en los que el
ejército combate contra otro ejército de
línea fíjense que en el 2020 que es el
último año que tenemos registros
completos y analizados hubo 40 guerra
no es que apareció la guerra esta semana
hubo 40 guerras en el mundo en el año
2020 y más o menos es así produciendo el
2019 y el 18 y los últimos 20 años como
cosas que no saben los medios algo que
suelen pasar suele prestar mucha más
atención que otros medios por los medios
masivos de comunicación no salen estas
guerras porque no salen las puertas de
europa son generalmente en áfrica
subshariana o en medios y entonces
realmente al público te interesa menos
al público occidental pero la realidad
es que esas guerras estados pero eran
diferentes entonces cuando rusia invadió
ucrania con su ejército de línea y
crearía tiene un ejército de línea para
ponerse eso es un fenómeno que hacía
muchísimo tiempo que no veíamos y
seguiríamos que no iba a haber más y
culturalmente nos requieran muchísimo
ahora alejandro hay en la guerra un
factor además de disciplinamiento social
digo funciona como una suerte de
mecanismo de control de las sociedades
ese es un elemento sin duda fundamental
no es un elemento estructurador el
ejército durante todo el siglo 19 buena
parte del gran interés pues el modelo
con el cual se armaban las sociedades y
se armaban los estados y se trataba de
darle a la sociedad un modelo jerárquico
copiado del ejército ahora desde la
segunda guerra mundial para acá hubo una
mutación cultural en la cual la mayor
parte de la población en el valor es no
pacifista digamos pacíficos que no
aceptaría ir a una guerra fácilmente lo
que está cambiando acá en lo que estamos
viendo es que esa cultura general sin
siquiera tiene excepciones locales
fuertes y rápidamente puede haber
mutaciones negativas digamos en este
sentido entonces que rusia puede atacar
a australia con un ejército sí como lo
está haciendo ahora nos habla de ejemplo
si estaba pasando algo que por ahí
estaba pasando un poco desapercibido
porque vemos hace tiempo por ejemplo en
europa occidental y en eeuu que la
población no acompaña este tipo de
aventuras bélicas de sus gobiernos
porque no tolera el número alto de bajas
que seguramente van a tener entonces que
los rusos acompañan a putin en este tipo
de aventura entonces está haciendo
llamar la atención y lo mismo con el
lado ucraniano es tan rápidamente no es
porque nos nos ha consigna cuando vemos
las noticias en una semana ciudadanos
del común están en el frente de
activando bombas molotov con
ametralladoras bueno me da a entender de
que en realidad una de esas guerras
limitadas que nadie veía pero que están
es la de bombas en india y rusia aprendí
a ser sueños que están en gasto y esa
guerra viene
terminando los valores y viene permeando
los discursos y las conciencias y las
prácticas de estos dos pueblos entonces
nos hace afrontar este conflicto con una
velocidad que para nosotros es
alucinante realmente no la podemos
comprender
hablemos ahora de la tradición guerrera
occidental no que ha estado constituida
alrededor de algunas ideas básicas que
serían la de gloria el honor y también
el coraje marcial esta concepción sigue
vigente o se ha transformado a través de
los tiempos
después de la primera guerra mundial
pero lo que fue la masacre de las
trincheras en la industrialización de la
guerra que un poco en ridículo ya hizo
este el pacifismo abordar no diciendo
acá no hay no hay guerra no llora no hay
nadie ninguna gloria para nadie es sólo
carne de cañón y miseria y de ahí sale
este cambio y esta mutación cultural de
la que hablaba en un principio porque
pasa es que el recurso
bélico
nacionalista
a las pasiones de la guerra sigue siendo
más efectiva de lo que nos gustaría
reconocer que son milenios que tenemos
encima que tenemos en los genes lo
tenemos en nuestra cultura de nuestro
cuerpo todos los por más fácilmente aquí
no se aviene de eso y la humanidad viene
conviviendo con está produciendo este
tipo de enfrentamientos desde hace desde
siempre y entonces es muy difícil
desarmar y cuando un presidente o un
general se pone a regular el sable voy a
decir de clases patrióticas y hablar de
gloria en heroísmo
lamentablemente a muchos televidentes en
hierve la sangre del deshace un efecto y
es así como muchas veces gente que hasta
el día anterior parecía tener una vida
100% pacífica también apoyando una
guerra
motivado porque no están realizadas
claramente
planteadas además alejandro el tema de
la composición de los cuerpos
combatientes un tema muy interesante
porque desde esta perspectiva social de
la guerra
el sujeto o combatiente excede el ámbito
de lo puramente militar o el oficio
profesionales no quemo de los
combatientes se configuran en este
contexto de estados de guerra
bueno los países occidentales
los estados desarrollados
como rusia network hace rato que optaron
por un modelo de soldados profesionales
limitar justamente como la población no
quiere participar masivamente de estos
conflictos se tercerizó se
profesionaliza y se hace un grupo de
discutir una subcultura de la guerra
apta para este tipo de conflictos para
lo que estamos viendo en ucrania es
fascinante en el sentido es una tragedia
obviamente pero en internet y para un
estudioso de la guerra es fascinante ver
como muy rápidamente la población civil
está participando en la defensa no me
pongo en la carne de esa gente que de un
día para el otro recibe un mensaje del
gobierno diciendo arma en bombas molotov
y realmente no hay manera de procesar
esa orden no hago esa sugerencia y se
salir a combatir con el ejército ruso en
la calle un día para el otro pero bueno
lo vamos a estudiar seguramente con un
caso
fascinante esto que está ocurriendo acá
porque el contraste es muy fuerte pero
ya te digo me parece que por lo primero
que veo
esta sociedad está más preparada para la
guerra de los pinos sospechar porque en
realidad por más de que en occidente no
salían las noticias hacia atrás con
alejandro rabinovich muchísimas gracias
por tu presencia en la entrevista de
france 24 en español ha sido un placer
dialogar contigo y gusto no nuevamente
gracias a ti a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a que sigan
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
sigan con nosotros
[Música]